so you sold the business for a billion
dollars in cash you make your investors
yourself everyone's walking away very
happy they take the drug and maybe don't
do what everyone thought was possible
with it and now you are sitting here and
somehow you have the drug and they gave
you cash and now you are running a
business with that drug again how does
that happen right there's only one other
person that I know so I'm gonna pick out
a little bit Doug loved sold Lending
Tree yeah they then grew it and if I
remember correctly they basically sold
it it fell like 75 80 % in value he went
bought it back or so he actually paid
for it and then went and grew it again
and so that is a story that's happened
before I've never seen somebody sell the
business and then basically the acquirer
says keep the cash get your truck back
head like leaves and here we'll give you
a loan so you don't have to be
distracted with fundraising yeah you
know it's an extraordinary story and you
get smarter to go along so I'll tell you
how that happened well first of all they
I could not have written this movie like
the way that it played out and maybe
it's the first drug for female pleasure
what's going to have the most great
insane story not only our story and
fighting the government but then you
know you win and and it's really like
the on hers dream come true we were 35
people when we created a billion dollars
worth of value 35 of us and you know
they were gonna March it across the
globe and make it affordable in ways
that we really couldn't at that moment
in time they take it they're gonna keep
me in all the team invite me to leave
three months later they dismantle my
entire team they put it on the shelf so
what happens is we announce the sale you
know takes a while before those clothes
on October 1 it closed that was in 2015
11 days later they got a letter from the
Department of Justice and there was an
investigation because they hadn't
disclosed this pharmacy relationship
that they had no one knew no
sophisticated investors or anybody else
knew and in the world
went boom and the truth is we were the
last thing in the door I was not happy
not having if I'm in the middle of about
to going to a launch and and so I become
a liability I'm gone
then the total team is gone because
they're trying to save the core business
which is burning to the ground this that
the day that we sold to them like they
were the darling they were 260 a share
they traded down into the teens so the
truth is it just got deprioritize it was
punished off and we have fought so hard
to finally women got one on the board
and the women who needed it couldn't get
it and I used to mystery shop it like
I'd go to Target can I get it no it's
not available crazy
so they got a new CEO if I got her CEO
total turmoil and he was on the job
about two weeks he's a lovely man and I
sat down and I said can I get it back
like we just paid your billion dollars
for I think this has a ton of value I'm
like well good I'm glad you remember
that because my shareholders do as well
and not in a threatening way but like
for real there's a lot of value here and
our transaction was structured so here's
where I got smarter when I sold slate
I got money out front and then I got
money on the back end I participated in
royalties mailbox money for years which
was great it but it was governed by
boilerplate language best efforts Clause
classic legal life estimates class well
actually when you do that what you
realize is well your best efforts and my
best efforts are different so like you
know as a founder you sit there like oh
they should be doing this I'm not doing
that and you like have angst about it so
when I sold sprout I wrote the same deal
we had all of this money coming on the
back end but it was governed by very
specific performance obligations and
they weren't outrageous they were like
how much money we spend on marketing how
much money we spend on field education
added another dot they weren't meeting
any of them so when they blew me off I
sued them
in the court of Delaware in exchange for
dropping the lawsuit I got the company
back and I kept a billion dollars and
got a loan to get started I win they win
they get a participation in royalties
but not a bad deal